Wow oh my god I just got the craziest
cure I'm Anna Kendrick and quiz to see
which character we are in pitch perfect
3 what's your favorite burrito filler
cuacamole rice chicken beef lettuce or
sour cream yeah I pick walk to you guys
that's kind of a loaded what are you
gonna choose what are you - rice so
close hope choose a Disney ballad a
whole new world let it go
buting the Beast I'm part of your world
I'll make a man out of you I definitely
have to say never I'm doing it I am -
I'm being true to my cuz that was cuz
every time you're in a pool you gotta do
this you know pick and acha phrase
excuse me
acha awkward polka [ __ ] acha gods I
like acha awkward cuz it's how I feel
but not now yeah I'm gonna do like a
[ __ ] well you know what it's the
cursing one so what type of college club
appeals to you the most
maybe in a camp should do this cuz she's
the only one who went to college
okay cool kids Greek life student
government a music club and academic
club a service club or an intramural
team who does an intramural team I don't
know and I went to college should you
how much I learned well if I could do it
now mm-hmm an academic club because I
would be going to learn more because I
like to learn expanding your mind I'm
into student government these days
because I think we need to get some
stuff worked out yeah those are really
bold specifics
okay you know she's a punny acapella
team name let's see how funny these are
sexy pitches tonal ecstasy Shirley
tempos trouble in paradise
one note stand uh uh-huh I see I'm not
gonna lie I I kind of a fan of these are
they I mean they're pretty bad but I
can't choose between Shirley tempos and
one note stand I'm choosing one note
stand there like that I'm doing trouble
in paradise I'll do Shirley tempos just
to make things right which female
musician inspires you is cash on here
she's not I think we can all answer this
at the same time I know you guys want to
do that but I'm I yes of course you know
I have to but I know as you pressured
you to like Beyonce no I do I love the
odds are of a lord gown that's your
ideal college major public relations
business engineering English biology or
none of these a engineering oh my god I
just got the craziest cure I got fatty I
got that Amy I got Becca I don't think
being Becca is bad you're standoffish at
first I was so extreme and your talent
never ceases to amaze well true I was
really hoping I would get Lilly RISM
[Music]